greetings from podcast Ville you bad
[ __ ] the church what's happened
now is sponsored by Stan's calm listen
time is money stop wasting your precious
time going to the post office when you
could send letters and packages right
from your desk do it today with Stan's
calm my wife uses it and it's one of the
best things we got in the house
sometimes I got I get home and there's
ten packages in the mailbox
bing-bang-boom she throws the shirts in
there she puts a label on them you weigh
em everything comes from stamps.com I
use temps calm you know why because it
saves time and money and but they're
both precious right now they got a
special offer for the church family a
four-week trial plus postage and a
digital scale to go to step now go to
stamps.com
and click the microphone at the top of
the homepage and use promo code church
that stamps comm and enter church and
start sending mail like a doctor with
Stan's Tom the podcast is also brought
to you by quit one of the most important
things we do for our health every day is
brushing your teeth yet most of us don't
do it properly quip isabella electric
toothbrush created by dentist and
designers and quip was designed to make
brushing your teeth more simple
affordable and even more enjoyable than
ever I love brushing my teeth lequip why
sonic vibrations they gentle enough on
your sensitive gums people brush too
hard and someone like the toothbrush is
a too abrasive quip is perfect you see
why I love quit that's why and I'll tell
you what I'm gonna do they're backed by
20,000 dental professionals clip starts
at 24 hours and if you go to get quit
calm slash Joey Jo ear out right now
you'll get your first repo refill pack
for free with the quip electric
toothbrush
that's your first refill pack for free
go to get quip GE t qu IP comm slash
joey let me explain something
everybody's looking for a good CBD
company well it ends today I got the one
I use it myself and I [ __ ] love
I'm talking about CBD Lyon they make
products from start to finish
CBD line got you covered whether it's
the vapes the cartridges or the shadow
and if you're not into [ __ ] smoking
oh they got tensions and they got these
gummies [ __ ] tremendous you get
stoned eat three or four gummies and you
pass out like a [ __ ] baby alright
their products are clean Bobby so go to
CBD line calm and check out their third
party lab results yourself third party
lab results yourself Church family gets
20% off your first order just press in
Church at the checkout take this
[ __ ] melee what are you [ __ ]
nuts or what Eleanor Kerrigan in the
house reminds me a trading places with
the real small to what he busted that
song I love that Jam a great that Jam we
lit Judy Kelly's teddy bear up one night
that his jam in the back of the car what
does that mean she had a teddy bear in
the back of the car and she's right
about her ex-boyfriend cuz he cheated on
them and we lit the [ __ ] teddy bear
on fire we're all coked up in the
[ __ ] teddy bears melting fire as a
kid you have to it was like a oh my god
if you know this damn you live on fire I
used to like more bonds I'm five
brothers starting a fire under his bunk
bed we were like what's that light and
then it was a he's like I don't know
what happened it just got bigger fires
get big my mom could have lost
everything
yeah when you were a little kid I
thought it would lighten fires and
pissing on when I was like six like you
Cuba I would hide a little fire in the
corner and be on it the street and the
fire control I ran out of penis and I
ran away the fire department from my
[ __ ] window yet you know we like fires
and it's far easier was bad with that do
you remember that he used to light him
all the time at the comedy store whose
terrible they might ride up a Vienna fly
and they blame
hey grandma somebody lit him on fire I
wanna know who it is because I waiting
for that on you I was in Miami
I guess they locked them in the bathroom
and they [ __ ] little monster I got a
call from Prince's quarry Lake did you
like Robert approvai on fire last night
I'm not even [ __ ] town be honest
though
did he give them the idea no been used
to call blue surfer and he'd be like
five burn up Lucifer burn up and he used
to light matches and throw them onstage
at him I used to pee my pants but over
there Eddie they're getting close I
didn't know they locked him in the
bathroom I forgot about that
what was the deal with him he didn't
like when you walk crosses oh wow Eddie
Griffin didn't like Wayne Garces on
stage I wish they'd get that Satan thing
off fizzy used to give them out on a
hard time you got that voodoo around
your neck maybe I don't know it's good I
hate when people wear two rosary bead
that gives me anxiety yeah cuz I'm a
Catholic suffice you know you're not
allowed to put it over you're not
supposed to put it over you know like
Madonna yeah and a lot of people do that
if you got him wrapped around your hands
and you're praying at the Traxxas mom
which I'm with you I took rosary beads
to the track one time I didn't wanna no
thanks give me the 20 you better take
those other beats Robin a real like it's
gonna come to life you know like when I
first became a Catholic like as a kid
like I still remember all the things but
once like I got in boxin ated I give you
ask God for something you didn't get it
I got the Mets better win today you got
man
you got piss like flood god yeah [ __ ] I
don't work is the Mets lost and then my
mom would say you can't ask for things
like that right that's what my mom is
why are you [ __ ] crazy
what is he for get it yeah the Mets
can't cover my two runs that much
probably because there was more people
in Philadelphia praying for the Mets to
come on one thing I think about one of
the Mets played the World Series how
many were there
86 Mets eighty six months ago I dropped
the ball at first but that's bet Bill
Buckner a Red Sox fan
it's funny how many people while I
praying like please God let him knock a
[ __ ]
like I told you God answered my [ __ ]
prayers it was between his legs
God hates that guy remember when they
put him in Curb Your Enthusiasm Bill
Buckner I mean and then it was a Jewish
thing you might know this where you have
to have ten people to save a prayer it's
yeah yeah what's it called the ten
people you have to have 10 people so
Larry David brought Bill Buckner and
they wouldn't let him in
they're like no he's bad luck it's so
great I love that they still wear as
that God my god well I'm Boston think
about getting set on fire I thought they
were gonna kill that guy that they're
gonna kill him too
didn't the guy Scott Norwood didn't he
miss a field goal for somebody Buffalo
Bills and he [ __ ] tried suicide
yeah well that's yeah like Buffalo
people talked him into it yeah he'll
come to your house listen why can't kids
what's his name when he talked to
Frankie five angels Godfather - he
talked them into commit a cab and at the
end they put a bat and they slit their
wrists and that's how they welcomed
Ian's always complaining about like the
negative stuff you got on social media
like I remember this year like the Bears
kicker missed like four fields or
something he must have had to delete his
accounts we had an entire city spending
of money from Philadelphia because it
happened yeah Eagle oh they sent in
money and his venmo thank you for
missing that kick thousands of dollars
people were sending up Philadelphia's
evil bro they had billboards of that guy
in Philly after that kick thank you to
the Bears for like crazy lit up
everything cuz I always thought that I
came from a weird neighbor I always knew
that that's not funny
not weird and the semi was wearing yeah
but it wasn't like the neighborhood's I
saw on TV it wasn't oh yeah I grew with
a shoe but I was growing up with was not
on the Brady Bunch
never but I never felt more at home then
when I went to Philadelphia the first
time isn't it the greatest place in the
world
sorry Lou it's not that it's the
greatest place at the world it's so
[ __ ] up
attitude they just don't give a [ __ ] now
my first contact with those people was
needed great when I went to when I went
to see the stones and I didn't know
anything about concerts I didn't know
anything about music really I didn't
know anything about social skills I know
nothing about leaving my name I thought
that yeah I know about social skills you
know but I didn't know that there was
people that were but I feel like that in
all these coasts now like you feel that
yeah you know I loved all them I loved
watching old sports things oh yeah
because they really show you the heart
of the country we can get to see like I
love to see Ohio State in college yeah
play you know they go crazy love
watching the Houston Oilers when I was a
kid when her Oh Campbell played yeah
anything like that people were blue and
white bonbons everybody yeah I'm doing a
unison but Philly there were just
animals like they were animals and I got
into the Sixers once Julius Erving with
became a sixer right my whole life was a
sixer and then zero Dawkins we showed
doubt we showed I showed some buddies
among simonia I showed him the Sixers
against the Portland Trail Blazers Clyde
Drexler this is way before Clyde Drexler
this is okay and [ __ ] they had a
tremendous team and Bill Walton was the
center because I'm like am I still in
Luminex a successful gonna lose but
Julius Erving slam-dunked so bad on the
wall and Bill what was trying to call my
offensive now I was always a fan of Bill
wall because he was happy and he smoked
all baby when he went for the offensive
foul against Julius Erving
I lost all respect to them like that was
done like just take that you got [ __ ]
slam slam and not only good again that
was old-school way to if you watch the
move it wasn't that he slammed on him
it's that he
took the Reba took the ball all the way
down court and looting defenders and
then it was just him and bill two black
dudes chasing and he just picked up that
[ __ ] ball and he goes you know what
bill I'm a losing game but you're gonna
remember this slam for the rest of your
life he just slammed in his face that
bill wall and you actually see bill
warping telling the wrath like no
offensive reps like I watched he was our
God he was my light I mean he we still
play games and call it julius everyone
jewel everything is julius [ __ ] he he
used to hook people julius erving then
let him get away with that for years and
i use that it's a little hook with your
hand
uh-huh and you hold the opponent's waist
and if you watch any of Julius's move
his best moves when he step out any time
you so when he put his foot back he
would take off so he learned how to put
his foot out and go back and fake and
when you came back he would take off on
you but he would take off on you as you
were coming towards him yeah but how he
got around you was with that hook yeah
and he would always hook you push you
and in that play you actually see him
like [ __ ] and hook and go walk you see
you always would see his hand to people
and he just drew it the [ __ ] down and
after that bill walking lost all
credibility of minds i don't give a [ __ ]
oh he's good looking yeah but he's 1982
i'd rather have an ugly coach you win -
you know saying i'd rather have that any
months - look boys from Arkansas he
looks just like grandpa the Munsters but
that [ __ ]
know Houston Houston when they had phi
slamma jamma the coach looked just like
any monster just like grandpa grandpa
well the [ __ ] he's good-looking and
he's got LeBron he can't make it put
players well good is he yeah but LeBron
pays by himself he's
I don't know what's going on tortured
yeah that LeBron Sixers are phenomenal
right now Celtics to Sixers are a better
team with they're both young Celtics you
haven't shot a [ __ ] ball in 22 years
there's need for you so but I never say
we well you remember I never say we won
today that's because Boston's a better
City than when you Frankie to say [ __ ]
and even throw a ball in high school so
you know I'm Jewish I'm sure know so
then let's say we you didn't we
Utena you guys get emotional watching I
can't make fun of women no matter what I
say who cares but like now when I was on
Instagram if I see like we plays
especially of the teams when I was in
school like I'll start getting almost
teary eyed oh yeah yeah we were talking
about Julie's talk about Julie's fight
and Larry Bird one of my favorites
Kevin by the throat to fight each
other's faces let's throw some punches
here picked him up it was Larry and I'm
a big Larry Bird fan too but it was just
so funny I was like oh my god Julie's
gonna kill him hand was like oh no Larry
talked a lot of [ __ ] yeah well Larry
just put low he was so good he didn't
have the same attitude
it was that stupid looking on his
[ __ ] face nursing everybody make it
look so awkward but yeah amazing Larry
Bird shot 40 points against you and he
wouldn't change expression I got a
crackle it's like his shorts were
getting shorter it was very uh he was my
favorite I mean Julie's was my favorite
top all-time but then it's Larry Bird
right after him is Julie's
everything still around yeah we're on a
flight last summer I was so neurotic
taxi cuz I go by the same way I said
next to Berkeley that's a love so the
again the last 10 minutes Julius Erving
I want to say anything I can just break
Julius and go isn't I went to your
[ __ ] converse clinic at Fordham
University in 1975 what do you have to
say about that
when you showed up with your kid number
Sadie's been and you got out of the car
all waiting online like little [ __ ]
morons that's the only time I weighed
online as a kid
this day yeah Oh shitty Converse
sneakers when Julius when Julius first
signed with the Sixers he also signed
they designed the sneaker from Connors
and it was called a limousine for the
feet yeah and he if you bought a pair of
his member sneakers worth converse with
1099 1119 yeah $10 if you get them down
Delancey Street the Jews if you went
down to the land pump on the first
customer of the day you get them in the
chinks in Chinatown to go for the chance
no chinks for the best but then there
was coach converse and if you walk coach
conversation you might as well put
punching bag on your head cuz you were
gonna get smacked 50 times it was a big
difference there was a dollar but he
coach converse and regular Commerce
Chuck Taylors yeah
so if you more than go the extra dollar
let me tell you some might as well you
know these people they get cyber bullied
that's nothing compared to the beating
you were gonna get beat him and throw
dollars that could only show up with
converse PF Flyers the second and cats
came in at say third that's hilarious
if you bought your sneakers from patty
pride if your sneakers slip the slide
take them back to Paddy pride no that's
it we used to talk about sneakers oh my
god consumer market kids come out with
new sneakers have been 10 minutes they'd
be sitting in the corner crying taking
the sneakers off drawn confident like a
shitty sneakers cos mu Tormentum
especially this big enable it's like I'm
40 it's up there with my godmother those
kids were poor
yeah but they made sure they had Chuck
Taylors arm because nothing is being
poor but if you had Chuck Taylors at
least you I you could step on that and
they would take him home every night
those poor kids and they would they take
that same toothbrush they brush their
teeth with and they would scrape the
Bubblegum with this [ __ ] off this
sneaker those sneakers are immaculate
you use a different tooth add one
she'll throw I hung out with a Puerto
Rican families to a poor they had one
toothbrush for the family it was like a
double you gotta pick a number you're
way down like number nine maybe get
cheaper scene and then the kid Ricky
would sneakier than my couch logic and
put like turpentine on let me show you
that and then after that you took white
shoe polish on you white [ __ ]
sneakers that's right like these kids
were so poor like I had taken life for
granted my sneakers would get dirty in
my momma throw more and buy me a new
pair sneakers oh that's crazy
we didn't Daniel's the Irish kids are on
the 40th street those sneakers lasted
you a year yeah you made sure because
you used to wash our sneakers some of
those kids if there was if it would rain
those kids on a Foley a street they
would just take this sneakers no run
around barefoot there was savages
because there's no sneakers meant
everything to everything everything to
them and then when the snake had died
you tied it together and you threw it up
in the air and how to get on the court
hmm so you would have 20 sneakers on
that cord as you were growing up on the
electrical cord and once a year the
[ __ ] guy from PSN's you would come up
with like a gas mask on [ __ ] gloves
and you have to take all the sneakers
down I mean there's just a process that
you did Oh judge by your sneakers I was
a drug dealer in the neighborhood no no
man that's what white kids fight like
they would come up with rumors I thought
sneakers on the line just meant it was a
drug deal of money no my sneakers on the
nobody take oh yeah that was the thing
okay
people wear those chucks till they had
holes in them what totally pop now yeah
hey some people wore Chuck Taylors today
50 year olds and above
I guarantee their feet of fine because
all there was with that cushion you put
a picture of Taylor's on today and you
feel the [ __ ] difference
yeah Jesus Christ a glass could go
through this mm-hmm
like a glass it's almost like being fair
to us I'm not a fan I'm gonna show top
kids
where I love my adidas shell top now
those you clean with a little bit of
soft scrub yeah my Mike my wife water
Eakins these up yeah I'm the time I got
the I got to walk around the stage once
absolutely show shoes and uh stage one
yeah I think stage adidas and I have my
regular deenis they stink like [ __ ] I
know you always say that I was a calm I
was I started off as a cat guy when I
came from Cuba then I went up to PF wise
and then I was Chuck I don't know what a
PF Flyers was flier 1970 71 72 PF flies
made you run higher and jump faster
that's hilarious
that was their slogan we had the pump
for that the pump came late payment like
later on when you pump them up and you
thought you were bad all the way running
and getting swatted down back it's
amazing story that I say on stage I mean
I tried it into a joke years later yeah
pfy I was never a fast kid okay I was
quick but in long distance you would
catch me okay all right so the marketing
tool behind PF lies was they make you
jump higher and they show a kid by
jumping a fence without touching it and
then they show my brother child made
sure I can call a Rican kid getting
chased by cops father the Puerto Ricans
high goal booth and giving up PF flies
and make you jump higher and run faster
but the white guy got away I went all
got the [ __ ] PF oh I begged my mother
gave me the PF flies but then I had to
put him to the test okay how did you put
him to the test you tortured silly Jew
on the bar his name was mr. martini he
would chase you chases for blocks
chases for boy and all that clothing in
the Black Sun his curls are flat okay
you only have like a little crown he
wore the thing he was the typical
slumlord
like what they come Lord tonight he
lived three house he owned three houses
that were next to each other bleeding on
the basement of the middle one so you
weren't even allowed they were metal bar
with those beers sticking out yeah like
little Chi Cheng's like that and wakeful
again you wouldn't even allow it to talk
in front of his house oh I hate people
like that a lot of people come out and
go hey go down a [ __ ] block if you
guys want to talk so the first time we
did that to me even at that age I was
like you don't own this file I was Cuban
I was trying to be American I thought I
knew all the American rules it's a free
country
yeah I probably gotta use that every guy
right off the bat it's a free country
Perry goes in a [ __ ] free you [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] blocks on my [ __ ]
[ __ ] really free okay I got me
and my own little dirty guys well he
just started on the small torture
chamber eggs to his building we act
everybody yeah oil of paper if we killed
a rat we [ __ ] around the [ __ ] thing
in that he come up with the rat in his
head and what one of these days I'm
gonna catch one of you little
[ __ ] and I'm gonna eat his for
lunch and all this [ __ ] he was [ __ ] he
was tough but mr. Martinez reputation
hood mr. martini caught you he'd [ __ ] he
did that too they kill you so all the
kids you were scared of mr. markoulis so
we would set him up with traps we would
[ __ ] with him with traps
oh yeah like if he passed it past the
corner you throw a [ __ ] stick Adam I
mean we had mr. martini tortured that's
crazy
then other kids from the block would
come on and I would make them go in
front of mr. martini it's like it there
ya go let's go play snoop one front of
mr. Martinez house that's when you slam
the ball no stoop wall is when you hit
the ball off the stairs you have to
catch it for a single or double so we
replace dupe warning yeah who's this
[ __ ] mind
he would come on say what I just tell
you a little [ __ ] so my mother
had a leg wha and this other thing a leg
wha is the thing that you put by the
door and you're supposed to put candies
in it and silver coins and pennies for
like luck so I would take a handful
change in those days those little poor
white kids they'd kill him on the [ __ ]
for a quarter because it was a soda for
so I would tell them come here guys you
guys want to make a corn and they would
go yeah and I would throw the corner
into mr. martinis basing it and
they would know that you weren't alive
and they would show the fans only kids
would come back to me beat up
I love [ __ ] you trapped me
mister much [ __ ] I would just take new
people and tell corner over there and
make them jump over and then one day
like I told you mr. martini for about
two years it was like a slow and summers
every businesses in Jersey
this is 12/5 West 88th Street okay we
were two or five he had to be like 198
uh-huh he was on the right-hand side and
we were on the left-hand side going
towards Central Park and dog we would
just hang across his house and say [ __ ]
so you we couldn't hang in front of your
house alright so now we cross the street
and that territory in front of his house
on the street we created that game
that's like pool but only you play with
like coins and you play and you have to
go through circles number one box you
remove the circuit on the chair dead box
and he didn't like that either
and then there was once day in the
summer where the trees would get
refilled with dirt balls [ __ ] balls no
dirt ball so it would be balls that
would just made a dirt ah
dirt that was compressed and they would
plant new trees and put those dirt balls
around listen you could throw all that
people and it just blow up
it would just be dirt when you got hit
with it that's amazing on that day was
mr. martini daily you know you have like
national donut day
yeah national Secretary's day whenever
those trees got filled up you knew to go
outside that you were gonna bombard mr.
martini at some point their day that's
amazing so we started bombarding him
with the [ __ ] dirt balls at first
little by a little Papapa Papapa we'd
run away and he chases and then one
winter I remember hitting him with like
a [ __ ] like a Kennedy assassination
of snowballs like Ford was not together
and he got hit with snowballs from every
[ __ ] direction but I had my PF flies
on I know
get away with him yeah and I ran this
[ __ ] all the way to Spanish
Harlem 88th Street Oh down to Broadway
and then after like maybe 90th Street we
just started walked it and it was
getting dark out like this is how he's
still following you yo this is how long
the truth was we started torturing him
when it was daylight yeah and we ran so
far and so long then when we were coming
back on Broadway it was already starting
to get dark I'll never forget this
yeah and it was Christmastime and these
kids think playing for tonight had to be
like eight of us or seven of us that
eluded mr. martini and at that time we
weren't giving each other high-fives we
were just walking back on fall camp we
got him and on the corner of 88th Street
there was a photography store and right
there some guys so Christmas trees I
will never forget this and we'll walk
and walk and walk in and as Bob we're
gonna make a left onto 88th Street to
walk to our perspective building mm-hmm
something made me look I saw the tree
jiggle little bit and I looked at the
tree and I saw mr. Munchie knees hand I
was [ __ ] guy
mr. Martinez hand put his hand to the
tree open it up he's a guy gotchas then
we all ran [ __ ] home that somebody
was asking me a couple weeks ago ago Liz
the like when I look at mercy now a Jew
coming out of a Christmas trees gotta be
work right was [ __ ] he was dressed in
the black and he chased us and ice told
him to hit my building and running up
the stairs I didn't have time to take
the elevator I didn't stop at three
because I knew that there was no that
staircase on the other side of the soul
everything or I had instead two
staircases
so I ran him up to like the sixth floor
then I hit the staircase and got up at 3
and went to my house on safer he never
[ __ ] of me again but that day I knew
mr. martini was gonna kill one of us
like I knew poking this boy only six or
five six seven that was what you did
back in the day you stay down we had
something called [ __ ] balls I think
they're called ginko balls for real
but I messed with Bobby Lee this was
part of the reason he got mad at me but
they fall out of a tree and they smell
like [ __ ] my mom was like if you go over
there just burn your clothes don't even
come home like because it would stay on
you so one day I was out there and these
Asian ladies were picking it up and I'm
like what are you doing with that and
she goes oh we make a soup I said what
the [ __ ] they're putting [ __ ] balls in
their food like it freaked me out so
when I met Bobby Lee I'm like to eat
[ __ ] balls and he got so mad at me yeah
at all at all nope really no way never
know not what I saw
[ __ ] that and then my my old boyfriend
in high school his dad used to like run
Chinatown I'm not sure what he did but
they used to always take us in the back
of a restaurant with the Chinese
no no I'm allowed to do that I'm kidding
I like that fought in Korea it's
disrespectful so no I'm teasing but we
he was an Italian guy and Oh
his name was Mario naturally and we his
that we would go see his dad I don't
know what he did up there but he had
some kind of connection or in I think it
was a loan shark I'm not sure so we
would go and we would go in the back and
my Mario loved it he'd be like get this
get that and I just be sitting there
like nauseous like there's [ __ ] balls in
there get me out of here I hated it I
never ate Chinese so I don't eat seafood
either I'm like weird no seafood no see
no fish no no no cuz the finishing my
dad used to take my brothers fishing and
then they would cut a fish open like
they throw the eyes at me and [ __ ] take
the teeth out look at his teeth yeah
here's his dick I'm like what fish have
dicks so you only chicken and meat
pretty much I didn't eat chicken for a
long time no I think that's why I'm
skinny I guess I ain't nothing a peanut
butter and jelly I don't I love the
concept of cooking I really love yeah
preciate the concept but cooking you
don't appreciate good cooking te [ __ ]
you know you see what kind of
preparation the cutting the seasoning my
mom you know I'm a firm believer like me
and him go to a place he gets the same
[ __ ] tacos every time they're the
worst talkers I've ever had because they
don't season the [ __ ] beef the carne
asada it tastes like they don't see it's
just beef with lettuce tomato on I could
taste that I don't want to taste beef
with lettuce and tomato on it I want to
taste the [ __ ] meat yeah the carnitas
are good the carnitas are good another
chicken taco guy yeah so but my point is
if I had a cook I wouldn't he
yeah I tell you this guy's silly chicken
is the most disgusting [ __ ] thing
I've looked at it please don't add any I
don't like I don't like chicken cutlets
I don't like dipping them I don't like
flour on my fingers you know so many
things I agree nada what I what I cooked
if I think if I really seriously want to
lose weight I have to cook because I
won't because there's only a seafood and
it's natural disgusting yeah it's big
you want to just eat them stage you
don't want to know how the cow slaughter
it like the whole would you be
vegetarian I'm close man there's wheat
there's weeks and months where I go
without it because I'll get nauseous
from something you told me to the burger
if you came to meet alele today I wasn't
alright doctor okay
and they did an EKG and they found a
little normally I mean the doctor will
laugh and it's nothing serious
yeah I want to get a test that but if he
came to me today and said Joey you can't
eat meat no more I wouldn't be upset
okay like the last seven years I've been
training myself more more so let it go
meet yeah you know to get off the meat
because it's just it's just for this age
yeah for this age I cannot go into
Morton's anymore
like 15 years ago what I never get yeah
I could go into a [ __ ] whatever steak
house for Joe and look at them and get
the 16 ounce prime rib
kill the potatoes kill the steak dip
tube
take half of his appetizers you know and
go upstairs and go to sleep
I would feel something you know what you
three that 20 is gonna be completely
different with you more than I am when
you could either 50 I know now like I
can't eat me that date o'clock at night
it's gotta be like four ounces something
like mmm if I go to a steak house so
somewhere with my wife for a date I
decide to eat meat I eat half the
portion I cut it right in half and I
give it to her there's nothing I like
more than what are you like fatty meat
like no I like steak like filet or you
go with the other one with the other a
ribeye well to get flavor you need more
fat to get the flavor yes Yankee I can
only do the filet and I like a well-done
like I just want what are we to [ __ ]
the place in New York
Lucas yeah awesome man yeah was it
Brooklyn yeah Williamsburg when you
taste of meat I know they spent time on
this yeah is I want you a long time yeah
I want your distinct flavor in this
steak
yeah you can you know I want I could
tell when I eat a piece of meat but you
didn't put no effort you know I don't
like chicken
same thing you know yeah do the chicken
yeah to give it that of salmon for
example is a hard thing to cook I cooked
it once it tastes like dick it's the
sauce you make with the salmon to
deviate that flavor is I'm saying I like
I like I like salmon but I just can't
eat a bagel rock sandwich
I need the cream cheese I need something
to tame that fishiness yeah I like
swordfish when you hit the dark spots
but it's so gross hearing them but you
know you have to when you eat fish and
meat all that stuff especially chicken
like I don't want to see it and let me
have some
I saw chicken go from the whole process
I'm gonna say that the Rhea guy
come on oh yeah hold them they take the
[ __ ] Freddie got a pray over
pray over it chop the head off milk it
yeah and then that night that sure
you're eating for dinner I was oh I'm
not eating that I don't give a [ __ ] I
was telling my wife the other day about
someone I got yeah I pray for my
daughter every day and I for my mother
saw because I can't believe I put my
mother through what I put her through we
would have an issue at the house right
now we're gonna move the baby we went to
some other people's house on Saturday
and they told this woman that daughter
was three it's not she was the queen of
sushi okay now she won't even eat sushi
when mercy was two she would eat the
black part of the salmon the bottom and
eat it like and chew on it black beans
white rice pork now she's six
that's a dull it see the chicken nuggets
or spaghetti every night sheets more
spaghetti than the [ __ ] Guinea I
never seen a kitty more [ __ ] my
daughter loves spaghetti everybody I'll
get spaghetti spaghetti spaghetti
spaghetti I told you I said listen man
you're growing you're going to karate
you're swimming you need protein so we
got to start [ __ ] it up
yeah you better start [ __ ] mean you
gotta sneak it in one there and the
mother one added okay go to bed it's the
last thing you want to do is fight with
Terry my wife came into that room as she
goes she's in bed seven o'clock please
and my wife was so pissed she went for a
ride because I gotta leave and I went in
there like at 17 I go what's up she she
wouldn't even look at me she was just
staring straight ahead because my mother
Terry pulled my mother yeah you're not
you know you don't get nothing go to bed
no food no dinner and I'm thrown away
the doughnut cuz we stopped and got
doughnuts after karate so my wife
[ __ ] threw away the doughnut there
was an argument there was yelling and
there was screaming he got a stick to it
man otherwise I told Terry what I used
to do at that time when I was six
already
and money in the back room yeah so one
day I was looking out a window and I saw
this company called chicken delight and
one day me and my friends there was a
blunt p-bass there was a pizza place and
down the block was this chicken place so
I just came from Qi
snowboy anything like that you could
slow that chicken off the block you
would think you smell more and one day I
went to that chicken place I must have
been about five and I walked in there
and I got a three piece chicken and it
was delicious with the [ __ ] french
fries that not the curly fly's wrinkled
cut crinkle crinkle cut and they give
you a little package jelly and I used to
dip the french fries dip the french
fries and then they give you a bun and I
would eat the bun I loved it so when my
mother would cook those up in tremendous
Cuban meals I would look at my mother no
I'm not eating she would go fine yeah go
in your room you're punished and she'd
be out there getting ready to go to a
bar and [ __ ] a couple of friends of B
over and next thing you know you hear
Bing bong yeah and my mother their
friends ago who's that at the door I go
it's for me right now
my mom yes I would and who's who who is
it and I'd say chicken though I don't
cook tonight cuz I was just learning how
to speak English I thought I was cool so
I would look at my mom and go don't cook
tonight go chicken delight and I would
get the chicken leg and I would walk
faster with a Tahitian treat they had to
deliver Tahitian treat the soda oh it
was like a fruit punch and a can full
and I would walk past my mother and I
can hear my heart my mother's heart just
going like I just cooked you a
traditional Cuban dinner I'll never
forget the first time she came in this
year like tears in her eyes she's like
you miserable son of a [ __ ] knowing now
I know why your father died to get away
from you because you eat that [ __ ] look
you're gonna die Metta guys you slammed
the door spit on the floor she did bad
day her puta how dare you eat that
chicken when I cook the beautiful meal
for you so she I got to the point who
paid for me cuz I [ __ ] man it was like
four dollars in a dollar tip oh yeah I
had that guy over the house four nights
a week my mother got
yes then she just stopped she goes I'm
not gonna compete with this [ __ ] yeah
but she might you crave Cuban food now I
would eat it every meal is C but we
don't know but you don't change your
taste buds change I have a nephew he
didn't eat anything I'm telling you
nothing he's skin and bones this kid he
hated every single thing he would go to
the bathroom it will come out white he
had nothing in him it was the weirdest
we were like you gotta eat
and finally like he's obsessed with my
other nephew little jimmy who plays for
the Minnesota Twins very exciting but
he's obsessed with him because he's a
baseball player and he's big and he's
athletic you know so Jimmy was like hey
well if you're not gonna eat like he
would have to mess with him and the
other my other nephew Brandon - he
wouldn't eat either
so Jimmy they lie to him and tell him
that chicken is pork cuz he won't eat
chicken cuz he got sick on chicken
nuggets so they're like no it's pork and
he's like all right and he eats it but
you have to lie to these kids to get him
to eat and we have to FaceTime with
little Jimmy to get him to get Conrad -
yeah I was a crazy [ __ ] now he's getting
better he's seven now so it's a little
bit better and I was popular because I
wanted to be on the other side of the
coin was I wanted to be American yeah so
I took by the more American food I ate
I'd become American hot dogs on the
corner sad breath I wouldn't have
pointed to of those [ __ ] I when I
loved when I was a kid not ashamed to
admit it Swanson's TV goodness
oh the salivary State my mom used to get
in the middle
I could eat 20 of those things and then
the superhero line was so mad at me for
that someone still makes right yeah man
yeah chicken wasn't bad so salty you can
fold your shoulders go up you're like oh
something's happening your heart starts
caving in no no that you eat it now [ __ ]
I have a passion for tea every once in a
while get like a regular chicken pot pie
a chicken pot pie ice tea's [ __ ]
that is gross but I the the butcher and
my mom's neighborhood they make them
fresh and it's delicious I would get
Prison and I can't eat your fake [ __ ] I
will need to top off the shell and the
chicken the carrots and the peas and
that [ __ ] got sauce [ __ ] you I'm not
eating that [ __ ] I don't know what the
sauce was these guys it's Italian
butcher and they make a beautiful they
make it great it's phenomenal I don't
know he's like chicken alfredo almost in
the pastry I tell you what
he's and carrot I'll tell you what I
always like since day one this is why
shocks me about Chinese Ashman I can't
live without Chinese that's amazing I
love it and this [ __ ] out here is
[ __ ] god-awful god-awful andrew has a
new one off to tell you about green
apples that's the one I don't know where
that is it's got the the garlic fried
rice am i having chicken and the Chinese
filet mignon I think Chinese can't roll
this is not good dumplings are not bad
yeah the spare ribs are not good I love
that this is all about food yeah couple
thing is a good day you just gotta watch
what you eat there that's it listen
people don't eat pork out here so spare
ribs brisket all that [ __ ] don't hold
out here but it doesn't thing about
Chinese food
my sister used to order it all the time
drove me crazy was it called um one time
one okay so then you take it out I go
what's in the middle she's like it's
pork but it was like a little brown and
then for some reason read a lot of it
what's it on [ __ ] I told genius over
here he would go to Koreatown amongst
funkin everybody's looking for a cat
she's got a missing cat that's right
he's like the dumpling you try don't eat
that [ __ ] don't eat the dumplings unless
you know even the back off or something
even the place I what it is is like
hotdogs the meat inside the dumpling or
the Chinese right it's whatever they
don't use oh we got an eyeball we got a
chicken
we got a lizard spine we throw it in
there we put some [ __ ] chicken and
they tell you whatever the [ __ ] they
want I can't I can't I can't because
when we would be in the back of that
restaurant with my ex's father I'd be
like holy [ __ ] yeah I don't think
was a sink to wash your hands I don't
there was chickens running around
I got a rusty cats running around I got
arrested one time one time and I was
getting transferred from Hackensack to
where I got a Burton County Jail
mm-hmm - go get arraigned at some other
job and I had neat okay I need and I was
a gentleman when I got arrested I didn't
know no big deal in my name we talked
and the cops I was transferring me I'm
in the back of the car and I'm like
listen man you're gonna take me to this
jail and they gonna put me in a Cell but
it's not gonna be any food I gotta be
honest you haven't eaten since like
[ __ ] five o'clock it's like nine
o'clock or one o'clock I had me right
late yeah I was like China I was
starting to lose a little bit
Ilia do me a favor will it drive past
chance dragon then do you mind if I stop
in there my I would they're worth four
felonies or misdemeanors yeah it was
possession of stolen property
weapons breaking you know that's it yeah
I think I sec you we the chance like
that's the best Chinese restaurant
Errani that's a noble story there's
couple years ago the detectives Bureau
there was a safecracker and he was
cracking safes but he was going all
around the area and that we had good
information that he did rest he that he
was doing he was doing restaurant mm-hmm
so he goes under our estimations we
figured Chan's is gonna be next so we
sat in the restaurant one night and we
waited so they closed and when they
turned off the lights we had to turn the
lights on after fifteen minutes because
the rats was so calm man I can't and you
know what I don't know to this day and
you still eat I still eat this I make
believe I don't know what I'm telling me
because it's so good if it's somebody's
can I can taste the tears and the salt
and the
you taste it to like this cat was loved
yeah you get euphoric and [ __ ]
or you know you pray for the best at
these places and you try to listen I
would never pulled pork in some way
there's just it's not made this foods
that if you eat out I like Sam would you
deserve to get food poisoning
you deserve to what's commonly yeah that
stuff I will need I look at the people I
refuse to eat like I just refused I'm as
picky as you are yeah seafood you gotta
be careful with it so you're gonna eat
seafood another fast [ __ ] place joint
you're gonna get [ __ ] sick I love
when people order it at a diner you go
to Jack in the Box or diner me a piece
of salmon you gotta get [ __ ] sick
you're gonna get [ __ ] sick you know
what's the one what's the one my mom
likes Eric almond bean no it's some kind
of it's the bottom of the it's the worst
kind to eat cod mmm that's not the word
I forget some fish you always order that
everywhere we go oh my that's the worst
it's like a vacuum cleaner fish yeah
it's the the bottom feeders they call it
listen not true that's what the world
think of what fish really split I can't
no we really is never thinking about the
Viren if you're a human and you really
sit there and say to yourself what am I
really a grouper at all levels at all
levels mm-hmm
whether it's beef how it was kept you
know when they did that movie about the
McDonald's chain oh yeah yeah they
tested it I'm a marina by the years
later then when they test a hamburger
patty from one of those fat food joints
mm-hmm there's a perception of weekly
fecal matter in that please that's well
known yeah you don't know that going in
you're a [ __ ] idiot yeah you know
that I do know what's going in yeah you
know when I read that whole thing about
if I go there I'm going there to hurt my
what I heard about the whole thing about
Vegas I read about this thirty years ago
well Paul Castellanos father was a
butcher okay okay Paul Castellanos
father was a butcher Paul Castellano was
causes with Carlo Gambino hmm and his
son Paul turned out to be the boss yeah
he knows that John Gotti shot it was
common knowledge in one of their books
they wrote the whole scam of how in the
50s they got after bugs he opened it up
they cut a deal with the National
butcher's Association or whatever in New
York
whatever your meat is on the shelf for
more than five days you don't lose we'll
pick it up when we deliver the meat and
we'll give you 50% of the dollar on it
so if a store bought that meat what they
did immediately would that meat was
taken back to a warehouse pack it on ice
and ship it to Las Vegas once it got to
Las Vegas they cut it out
and they dipped it in a chemical I read
this whether it's right or wrong it
makes sense
pink for three more [ __ ] rise and
then that's the steak of eggs you eat
for 199 right you go to Vegas and you
look at me [ __ ] idiot when you go to
your room and you get up in the middle
of night that for when you go to pee you
get that little runs another piece of
[ __ ] comes out the runs isn't sufficient
to make you think yeah you follow me
yeah I know I agree I'm a dusty well we
put so much in so many so when I read
that I did early age I know you know
when you see those guys in New York
sitting here and you're swallowing down
those hot dogs on the corner mm-hmm and
you're swallowing down those hot dogs in
the corner you know look at that water
yeah you know yeah time they get their
hands dirty they take an ice cube yeah
then they throw in the water they take
some of that hot water rub in their
hands and they bit you know you have
pinkeye I don't know how you ago these
things yeah I agree
when you go to a restaurant you're
judging it by that don't get me wrong
you go to Peter Luger and get a bad clam
you've got a sure let's see if legal
seafood and either bad oyster of that
clamp that happens but you know the
higher percentages you know like the
denikin they inspect their [ __ ] daily
yeah they pay a guy an hour to open up
each chunk check it out look at the
lobsters make sure
a lot about Java shells did you ever get
like the nuts in New York I haven't been
in New York in a while so no never
I love the smell of it but I've never
eaten them they still have them I was
just there three weeks ago they still
have ask yourself a question it's a
great smell I don't know I love hot nuts
normally but I'm just kidding I don't I
don't get nothing you have to look at
the animal you deal with exactly you
have to decide yeah lucky for me I got
food poisoning a couple years ago and I
can't even blame it on that
but you flame like a 24-hour food virus
stain well who do you blame that what do
you mean like if you got sick from a
restaurant I ate that 20 times I never
got sick before the taco stand by the
haha
across haha next to the sushi place
mm-hmm
that play and then sushi for example
gauzy ACK yeah the biggest place was the
mall or Weight Watchers is on Ventura
across the burger place what's the best
down stout across and stout on the
second floor was all you could eat sushi
and wheels and all those [ __ ] guys
would come up then oh it's great and
I'll never forget going up there the
first time and going
I'm not even a [ __ ] yeah that's I was a
poor [ __ ] comic that was like I'm not
eating [ __ ] I was that smart I got back
in the car and went right back to
Wendy's and got my 99 cents junior
burger scrap ball the chili for the five
hours it was working yeah that's [ __ ]
sushi place they had sushi waiting out
there for five minutes obscenity
that's where it ends with me when I go
to a restaurant I just went somewhere
I'm not gonna mention the name but two
weeks ago when I sent the order back you
know why because it's flu season you got
my dish in your [ __ ] hand and you
stop and start talking to stuff from
another way too
though you were talking on my food for
ten minutes he just froze next time you
have somebody's food yeah never bring it
to the table and then have the
conversation later they had a two-minute
conversation with my food like if you're
saying go get table whatever and you
turn
your head that's fine but if you it was
not a white dude try to be kidding I'm a
food server and kept talking to the guy
having a fire both of them and I was
like Touhou I don't a minute
you talked over my [ __ ] clamps for
[ __ ] damn it go bring me some know
what bro she just looked at me and she
knew not to say a word because I would
have worn with the [ __ ] manager oh
yeah my food to the table don't you know
the talk to nobody
yeah she bring my food to the table
Agrius do not stop top thousand things
that look I used to go to a restaurant
Cuban place I love Cuban food mmm you
know I stopped going there
why cause the windows with dirty I know
you can't wipe the windows yeah where
the door is
I can't eat at your place yes that's ok
it shouldn't look like a shag that's a
detail that cannot be missed by a busboy
an employee a bartender a waiter there's
certain things that cannot be missed
yeah that I will fire you on because
that detail that's a detail I cannot so
not one person that you have working in
this establishment can notice that these
windows were dirty I can't do business I
love them and that's it you have nine
because not one person took a look and
took initiative to get a newspaper and
no piece of Windex and just go like this
and wipe the [ __ ] thing that it's
seconds it takes takes a second so when
you go and keep a customer and I'm gonna
tell you something not a ten kitchens
you going I'm not gonna be a ratings no
especially why you're moving and shoving
a kitchen the Nance what let's be honest
you know many times I dropped a piece of
[ __ ] steak on the floor and I got ten
cats and I'll pick them up I got a
bubbly never coming to your house for a
second I know my sister but meanwhile
you blew some guy and me mini apple is
that you didn't know yeah you know we
have to all be in perspective here of
what no I agree yeah
when you go to most restaurants you're
an action shit's gonna it's gonna have
you know
piece of hair is gonna fall out of
somebody's head I understand all that
[ __ ] there's certain things that I don't
understand that yeah that's what Abel
like to feel [ __ ] on the table we gotta
go yeah we gotta go we gotta go if I can
feel dirt on the table not what he is
yeah I look at the tower use yeah if
it's just a towel from the counter that
they've been using all day get up
oh so I understand like when you eat
anything you know what if when I'm
picking the lettuce I'm picking my nose
[ __ ] lettuce jaw throw it's all the
same I literally so this is why you have
to think to yourself that at every level
you're eating something that's [ __ ] up
yeah and really sit down and think about
it you won't eat it all you become a
balance I'm Claus all over you telling
you I'm so close i skeeve a lot of [ __ ]
I'm so weak qualifing these same yeah
skis give us ice-t the [ __ ] food I
ski what are you Paul I told I told Lee
when I first moved here in your broke
comic there wasn't a weak Titan go -
what's the Arab place ungawa on
Hollywood Boulevard I'll be uh I'll be
here I'll be gone I'll not be not going
there for sure whatever I don't know how
many sure yeah I was named know how the
alley was here Ali was here then you
call the place and he goes I'll be there
no I'll leave Ali was easy what kind of
food is it Mediterranean is to die for
like I used to go there three times a
week Josh wolf [ __ ] Mitch Hedberg
always cheap
yeah Bauer okay I'm gone Hollywood
Boulevard if you make a left on
Hollywood God what's in there disgusting
strip I would never go in there I would
never let them give me the hummus the
hummus is like baby like hummus is beige
it's [ __ ] disgusting
all that [ __ ] like that stuff there
you'll die even harder like if you get
that [ __ ] that's bad tell cause it Isis
peanut butter yeah for this it's
disgusting it's [ __ ] disgusting to
even think of I like my neighborhood you
get a smack in the hand if you even
Brooke
ya know got bug wakka moly till I moved
to California never in my life have I
seen an avocado in Philadelphia see
Cubans will grow a real avocado see you
guys out here in Miami in Florida you
get those [ __ ] Mexican avocados go to
Miami how many that's this you don't
need ever coddled Oh
oh my god a little sliced avocado the
turkey and Swiss sandwich with some mayo
and some tomato good googly moogly
no really I I've never seen it I drove
past that place today what I'll be back
the heart doctor oh the place that makes
that sandwich I'm [ __ ] Hollywood
Boulevard that you love oh I've got a
little turkey and Swiss nice tomatoes
will shredded lettuce are you Turkey you
don't need to check my swing
really I know I'm telling you I'm the
worst year I'm sorry what do you even
fruit only go sometimes I'll have an egg
like a I got back into eggs it took I
was out of that for 10 years I'll just
like scramble an egg you know no toast
no it if I'm at my mom's she'll usually
throw in toaster bagels if they bacon no
unless my mom makes it because if you go
to a restaurant you order bacon they
usually microwave it it's [ __ ]
disgusting
microwave it becomes robbery so I got
turned off about ten years ago for me
for lunch
usually a PowerBar I love pasta I need a
lot of pasta and I'll usually put like
now I'm trying to put vegetables more
the past year cuz I realized there was
an entire year what I didn't eat
anything green because I'm terrible I'm
terrible at that like Ollie peanut
butter and jelly
I'll eat peanut butter and jelly on
crackers I'll eat like chicken I'll bake
chicken and cut it up and then now I'll
throw vegetables on it but before I was
just used to eat that with pasta by it's
like no green a lot spaghetti sauce I
like sometimes marinara certain ones I
don't make it at about you lasagna if I
make it if my mom makes it I eat it I've
got forbid I
how to make it like she does and make it
for myself a short date to an Italian
restaurant yeah I get chicken parm
I'll get pasta marinara with chicken or
chicken alfredo I like that one
sometimes it's gotta be done right
though hamburgers
I like hamburger cheeseburger steaks
potato yeah
this simple yeah steak and potato I'm a
really really cheap date just in case
anybody's looking but no seafood no no
see it's a young age just know my dad
would bring the fish home and put it in
the drain board like it was just gross
it always made me sick boy I feel like I
put fish and bees together because I was
always getting stung by a bee while they
were fishing because I was grossed out
so I would like wander off and that I
get I mean surrounded by really do you
really think I am a little slow I'm a
little messy good now let's get away
from the beef and chicken there's
nothing else [ __ ] about what's really
really in the ocean grilled cheese I
like grilled cheese because I'm what's
really really really in the ocean yeah
didn't they do a test on the beach in
Santa Monica and there was like [ __ ]
drugs in there
oh yeah there's needles coming up all
kinds of [ __ ] you know so you have this
wildlife I mean I know what covered was
60% water or whatever I've never been in
the water out here have you in the beach
yeah yeah I don't do it Jersey I'll do
it all day while what yeah that's why
you glow in the dark because you slammed
on the Jersey Shore with the radioactive
[ __ ] come out with a mess let me ask you
something
how long did you work at the store
before you decide to come up on stage
twelve years and throughout that time it
wasn't that you wanted to do stand-up
nothing never that's why
Mitsy and I got along so well because I
don't want stage time I wasn't I didn't
go help her for something in return
you remember when all the mooks used to
show up at her house Smits let me help
you you know with this today could the
only one it was stage time some of them
were robbing her I'm not gonna mention
any names but they were there all the
time using her phone call in New York
you know or just taking her food looking
for jewelry I'm like the [ __ ]
like thick but so she trusted me because
I don't want anything from her like
stage time so after Freddie died is when
everything kind of went haywire in my
head and I was like what are you doing
so it was kind of like this is your life
moment and Freddie always was like you
should be doing stand-up we could go on
the road together and I'm like you just
misery loves company you know I'd always
throw it back in his face and then after
he passed I I told Mitzi I said I'm
gonna do this one-woman show she's like
oh honey that's great do it in the belly
room you know so I did and Andrew came
to see it and he was like you're doing
stand-up stupid and I'm like no no no
this is a woman show I'm gonna talk
about my family I'm gonna tell these
crazy stories about South Philly like I
always joke about South Philly is like
Flint Michigan but we didn't complain
about the water we just kept drinking it
so that's why we're a little off you
know I mean like I would tell all these
crazy stories about my friends and stuff
and he was like no it's stand-up and
then he took me on the road with him and
then I got booed off the stage that was
pretty bad in New York and he and ruk
fired me for like a year because he was
like you got to see if you're really
serious about this like a lot of people
get into it and they think oh it's easy
everybody does stand-up all you go to do
is get a podcast and you know then
they'll give you stage time that's not
how it works you really got to be
dedicated to it and Andrew wanted to see
if I was like just [ __ ] around or
really into this and then I would go on
stage every night anywhere I could for
lo a little over a year and then he had
me reshow case if you will in Vegas what
Andrew told you couldn't whan the road
no more were you angry with him no did
you see where he was coming from I did
because in New York it was so bad when
they booed me off the stage so bad and
what I'm telling you that we were at the
Westbury music there a theater so it's
in the round so people are hating you
from the back the front the sides I'm
sweating so bad like my half raw slid
down looked like I had tumors on my
stomach like it was brutal
and I'm trying to get lines out
nothing's happening there boo
[ __ ] you Philly stink Philly Bubba just
because I said I'm from Philly
you know any means and I remember
catching eyes with my sister Karen who
drove two and a half hours to come see
me do stand-up you know three months
into stand-up pretty much I'm in front
of all these people and she was all
excited and I remember locking eyes with
her and she looked at me like what do
you want to do I'm gonna fight this
whole [ __ ] room I'll fight everybody
in here and we look exactly like we're
10 years apart so I remember being like
alright my sister's here calm down just
figures out wrap it up I think I did 5
or 6 minutes even though they were
booing the whole [ __ ] time I got off
and Andrew was like [ __ ] them I'm not
going on
I saw how hurt he got like he's like
that's my family you just hurt my family
you don't know who she is to me so he
wasn't gonna go on and then he went on
and beat the [ __ ] out of that crowd he
had the best that I've ever seen him
have and I went upstairs and cried for a
little bit and then came down and
watched him and people in the audience
were like oh we just wanted to you know
see Andrew we weren't we didn't really
care about you sorry about the booing
and I'm like sorry
[ __ ] kill you like you no idea what
that did to me but all that did was
propel me because now it pissed me off
you're saying I'm not good enough or
whatever you know and I couldn't handle
it
Andrews a purist oh absolutely
Joe Rogan's appears mm-hmm and I gotta
tell you something as much as a piece of
[ __ ] I am I'm a purist when they come
absolutely if I had to speak my mind
about what I really think of comedy a
lot of people would not be happy okay
it's true because I don't like a lot of
nonsense that goes on there's a lot much
of it more power to them I was always
trying to strive to be a [ __ ]
comedian so I know when somebody's
faking the [ __ ]
absolutely I don't even have to watch
this set when somebody comes to me and
says I've been doing stand-up for four
years and that
listen I've heard this story a thousand
times I was that story though don't come
on to me [ __ ] yeah
I'll hear about you if you're real well
here yeah that's right
here because all the years at The Comedy
Store my love and appreciation grew
thousand times bigger than ever like
that's why I would say I can't be a calm
not a comic I'm a [ __ ] waitress I'm
not one of you people like I thought you
had to have this as a kid I want to be a
stand-up you know what I mean like every
comic I talked to that I loved every
comic that was genuine and stood out you
know the the Judy goals that saw my rare
is the Joe Diaz is the Joe Rogan's you
know all these guys that came through
that Brian Holtzman that that really got
Doug Stanhope like you watching you're
like mesmerized and there was thousands
of comics in between them but they
didn't stand out there are just people I
know from the Comedy Store you know they
were trying to milk it if you will so
the ins and outs of comedy I knew you
know I just didn't think I wanted it now
I don't know what I'd do without it
which is what it's 12 years now I'm 12
and 12 is that crazy 24 you and you
watched it watch why write jokes and day
one bomb I want my Freddy ba I watch so
many people people come in with heat
yeah disappeared like people just
disavow compete like they didn't even
exist there's so many of them we watched
my first ex-fiance was a booking agent
right so we watched I went on the road
with Chris Rock watched him at the store
when he was doing bringing the pain
watched him at the store do it then we
went to the Riviera sure rippers room
and he was building it there so I hung
out with Billy for the weekend you know
and watched Chris and then in Jersey at
Rascals
I watched him build that that amazing
one of my favorite specials it's
definitely in the top five
bring the pain Chris Rock it's
tremendous but when what I'm telling you
I watched him bomb and not bomb and take
a joke build a joke fix a joke or perish
whatever word you want to use like it
was
nominal like that like Mitzi always says
comedy stores a college and she would
say well he went to the best college
honey because the 12 years I got to
study that I mean I should be a brain
surgeon 12 years but I was I had to go
and you know I got a double check
everything so I check all my prices
online so the club isn't [ __ ] on me
and I went on The Improv website and I
went to click on about two months ago
and I was Highland just I was at night I
was killing time you know I was going
through the comics that were going and I
found out I see all these Instagram oh
that's a fabulous YouTube people up and
it's like I get it to chat power to them
it's a check but where I'm coming from
and her you ain't it doesn't hurt me
doesn't hurt me at all doesn't hurt my
business doesn't interfere with me I
feel for them because I know what
they're about to go through you know all
this [ __ ] is great until something like
that bad happens and then you think
about all this [ __ ] you could have done
I saw McGregor holding onto his hands at
the car beep he wasn't thinking about
the check he was thinking about all the
time he wasted I'm not working what he
should have been working on as hang well
I shot my Netflix finish on the ride
home I knew what the recipe was that I
wasn't doing and now I'm sticking to it
that's why I am doing what I'm doing
today hmm
but I saw something years ago I saw a
comic that was young handsome had all
the tools to be a comic mm-hmm and he
was a great writer okay and he got good
at a certain Club I'll never forget this
he got very good at a certain Club and
that was a Hot Club at the time okay so
since the guy spent a lot of money with
Gersh you know it's like if I give you
if I high all of your [ __ ] ten comics
at that time Kirsch had Rogan and Wendy
Liebman it was the hot boutique agency
back then and he gave them a lot of
business so one day he
his hand and this could have been doing
calm me it is I'll never forget still
going to the club and the guy looking at
me and like sizing me up and I look at
those guys and I go you know you might
have [ __ ] had a good set last night
I'm at the store I need you up alive
I know shame never even thought of you
dumb [ __ ] and I remember I was
doing a - Oh one-nighter together
like me being in the car when I'm and
listening just think I just been doing
this for tweeze what the things I'm
doing already and I'm sitting it's
almost like he's telling himself I know
you killed the other night Dave Attell
told you this no yeah yeah yeah they
patted you on the back you also [ __ ]
bought drinks and brought the coke yeah
so we drove to the gig and he talked
another gig and the whole thing you know
I go up there and then about three
months later I hear that this manager
has set up showcases in the back of my
mind I wasn't wishing this kidney bad or
anything bad I just I just know the deal
yeah I've been here through long I've
been doing it for too long and I knew
the deal at that time I had been doing
comedy if it's 27 years and this had
happened at the store I was still doing
below so it had to be about 2005 mm-hmm
and I'll never ever forget this year I
quit I will never ever forget this I
remember was a Sunday night hmm I was
hosting and my top agent at CAA today
was an assistant that Gersh oh yes Blake
bat bleep Matt Blake what's it the
chicks
assistant yeah it was two big guys at
one point yeah the wig and the blonde
one that was something like that
chick that was [ __ ] all the black
comics we're not gonna mention no names
wait a minute there's two in this chick
go on the road girl black guys up and
then bring him back put him on freaky
Monday in one condition
that they would sleep at a house you you
just lay up my couch every black guy no
said they got up and she was Harvey and
his dick polishing that [ __ ]
and nothing about but one black dude
fell in love with was out there bring
roses and they put a restraining order
on him then they made her a live aged it
somewhere she sucks so much but Matt
Blake was the assistant then yeah my top
agent today
yeah so just to let you people know what
happens in xx is that assistant you
talked to when you first moved to LA 20
years from now he's gonna run a commie
division yeah so he runs the comedy
division at my agencies the top guy yeah
wait he's a William no he's a CIA Matt
Blake oh shoot what I'm doing a move
I know what I messed up the wig is agar
still because he's got Chappell that's
doing that Q so man yes yes yes he had
call yeah then he fought when the wig
yeah at carlo's and Rogan the wig and my
ex used to really realize it's I know
know that I know you're talking about
the wig from ICM no that's a different
way girls I would there's a guy that I
see and the guy the guy Hirsch doesn't
wear a wig I just say he has a wig sit
I call him to his face he hated him
everywhere yeah what he called Rogan of
until Rogan to apologize to Carlos yeah
I remember
I've been told to go [ __ ] himself fire
them yeah that's David Tao fire but
everybody else fired him because it was
a Rogen comment and David tell stuck
with him so James you know Dave
Chappelle
so that's the only reason why he but
there's two wigs is that wig in the
other way so what are we talking about
so I'm at the Comedy Store I'm hosting
on a Sunday night
I'm ran my own business I'm not
bothering nobody admits he's dead no
kind of it's he gets there about 9:30
8:30 she walks into a chair and I go
over what's up it's fat baby and she
stabs me in the stomach makes the air
come on
and I go to her you know MIT some host
in the second half and she was
absolutely and all of a sudden Blake the
club holder this he was the pseudo club
owner right club right told everybody he
was dealing abhi was really a general
manager yeah and the comic that he
thought you know was God are nice that I
looked through when I was like this
guy's got the balls of girl he's like I
didn't wish him any I didn't wish him no
bad feelings people what I did feel was
bad thing because he was going into
arena he was not prepared for that's
right he was not prepared a different
animal on it at the two-and-a-half year
mark I don't care what smoke that
blowing up your ass in your neighborhood
you were not ready for a Sunday night at
the store front of me she's never
telling you right now I'm telling you
right now so they come up to me and they
go hey we spoke to this talent
coordinator and he said it's okay if
this kid goes up I recognize every bug
everybody you know me what's going on
Michael I'll bring you up I go up to MIT
see me being me and I go Mitch I gotta
put this kid on I guess he kind of deal
with Scott day or whoever was the talent
coordinator at the time it wasn't Corey
yet this is way before okay then I had
to be Scott there yeah so I go uh I'm
gonna put him up I go they say he's the
Bill Hicks of the future and I say that
as a joke tour but what a serious face
anything
they call him the Bill Hicks of the
future okay I'll put him on next this
kid threw out his [ __ ] joke of the
year and it's the original rumor his dog
he blew out his a material and it was
like giving him a shovel
just like they just tapped him on the
shoulder when he got a stay is the
spirit of Richard Pryor tapped among
shows a by listen and say hey buddy take
this shovel
look what you're about to cause I got
the one minute mark she's in the
backyard
yeah
Oh Bill Hicks my ass right bill hex is
turning in his grave god yeah yeah his
kids turning you just you could see you
could see like she was brutal to you
come here a minute his hands went away
you could see the purple going up my
body you could see the purple and then
you could see the purple hit his face
and he just put the [ __ ] microphone
back and he walked off the stage
probably went outside and I'll never
forget his manager his so-called manager
a girl and the guy from Gersh just
turned their back and he stood there
looking around and nobody would look at
him and then they're like okay we done
yeah let's call the Improv and this kid
you could see that he had gotten punched
in the stomach
hard his manager and the guy from Girish
walked 10 feet ahead from us away and
I'll never forget this lesson and here's
how this les events I went to that town
a few weeks ago I asked a lot that kid
okay he's a bartender
it was too much it was that night
devastated him he'd wanna he went on to
do the improv for some songs and he went
on until do the Laugh Factory he hooked
up with a girl he did Tommy like maybe
10 more times that's it and that was the
end but the comedy store I'll do that to
you because it is a purist well it's not
it's not that
Tommy's don't do it to you is that if
you play that game eventually that's
gonna happen exactly yeah that do not
belong there
yeah but guys like I guys like Andrew
yeah Joe Rogan there's a lot of guys
bill burr there's a lot of guys that
know because not because we're trying to
be critical of you I've heard bill burr
talk about this Monday morning but it's
not that we're trying to be critical for
me is that we've been there yeah we've
lied to ourselves when I was at the for
you well I was doing comedy a year I was
telling people I was a comic
yeah Bob I still remember bombing of the
private I got a private and my two and a
half year morning I got a private
mmm-hmm they didn't want to pay me I
could I couldn't
collect the money from them we couldn't
make Ikon perpetrate a fraud yeah it was
a fraud fake it till you make it kind of
a thing is what I get everybody doesn't
like dice we joke about him and Tony
hands cliff does it a little bit too
like I always tell Tony that Andrew
always says he's very similar to him
because he was Tony too always pushing
himself all the way I'm the guy up
rising comic whatever I'm the greatest
up-and-coming comic but it's he has what
to back it up but he also is just like
putting it out there kind of a thing and
part of it is kind of [ __ ] with
people but dice he wouldn't do a movie
unless he could be dice like he would
wear his own shirt that said dice like
he put it in your face he's like the
original like Brander if you will that
he did two movies where he played the
dice character that he was trying to
sell to people pretty in pink
and I for for making the grade no no his
name was dice Ford Fairlane
he was Ford Fairlane that was his what
that's right that's right so dice was
but he was called the dice man in making
the grade and in pretty and pink that's
a huge movie John here is it's pretty in
pink with you pick that they're going
the dice man everybody says the dice man
and he has a shirt that says dice so
they're like whose's dice man you know
do you mean like that's not ultimate
Brandi but that's what he did and then
he would go around and tell people I'm
gonna be the biggest comic in the world
and they would be like [ __ ] out of my
face is 20 something year old kid from
Brooklyn I'll smack the [ __ ] out of you
and he's like no no I'm gonna be the
good world but he did it so it's like I
remember the respect but you have to
have what to back it up Lemmy started as
a [ __ ] Tony
uh-uh John Travolta oh yeah his father
would have to drive him to the [ __ ]
mafia gigs and he would get up there
with a white shirt and he do Jerry Lewis
he did Jerry Mercer and he do for a good
thing and come back as a Travolta
Travolta
I mean it was a software about that yeah
he's suto young so his parents had to
drive his father he told me start
yeah daddy [ __ ] drive them to what
was the club which I bought to film that
movie oh yeah got a cease and desist
because of that yeah it's crazy to stop
doing always had and you always had
chance because he started as it's like I
always lie to people I tell people I
started a [ __ ] prison of the first
time I thought I was doing comedy I
started playing the congas and my
mother's bar oh now he's a kid I get a
conga put a hat out and I just put the
jukebox on I would play the congas and
people would pay me this time like ten
bucks I'd stop I'd put it away and go
buy some I would play the contest and
they would say enough yeah enough we
can't [ __ ] think and my mom would go
it's genius at least you're making ten
bucks for yourself he's gonna order more
that Medicom fool have to give you
[ __ ] money yeah that's what started
that man that you know then the number
one bus and then I live in LA one began
to call me you know that's amazing but
we were in prison you said you will not
watch when I was him what I always
watched and okay so I watched in let's
get something straight
I heard the [ __ ] crazy and I lost my
mind then I bought Bicentennial [ __ ]
was it something I said yeah I got into
it I was into it I my brothers played
when I was a kid and people plump up
music on the Johnny load she's a rich
girl and she going too far take that off
I'm walking on I'm puttin [ __ ]
Richard Pryor no I get it I had no idea
I was a criminal I had no idea no idea
no idea no idea then when I was 27 I
started running out other options of
things I really wanted yeah and I said
well I tried electricity I tried this I
tried that I tried this I was a
bartender I might as well try stand-up I
don't see what I mean that's amazing I
that's al Madrigal has a joke not a joke
but like we always talked about when
everything else fails try stand-up like
like I came out here to be an actress I
wanted to be an actress I kept getting
engaged to idiots
you know informed
and getting in a play nobody comes to
plays out here
then I became a wrestler right some
issues there but you don't like I was
doing these kid shows and stuff on
Nickelodeon like I had I was doing stuff
but not enough you know anything like it
wasn't it just wasn't clicking I guess
and I would go to class all the time
I'll do know I know you were always I
don't be you were Freddie get light so
ontology they couldn't go on auditions
DW Brown your Freddie trying to justify
it to me and I'm like Freddie you'll be
arrested sue got rashes so you're cool
but you're never gonna tell me no I'm
not gonna audition that's right cuz well
how was it advantage Chubbuck I went to
revenge oh yeah yeah and I was already
starting audition and they were like
well we don't know what don't you know
what is it don't you know that you don't
know if I'm gonna make money if I'm
making money obviously your acting class
is working we'll leave it at that
yeah and I'm gonna go out but you're
never gonna control me and tell me I
can't listen to that he quit the second
year to go on tour everybody was Shepard
- she quit telling you with acting
classes you're not ready
I'm a stand-up I come from a different
world they're not ready yeah these kids
that get out of college and took a
peanut program that's right here they're
not ready yeah I'm ready I'm at that
store [ __ ] nine nights a week yeah
following Mooney and the lights of this
guy and Eddie Griffin so even though I'm
not a seasoned actor I'm three-quarters
the way here I just gotta find my
[ __ ] way yeah and I did you know
eventually I found out why Mitzi shore
gives you three minutes spots yeah at
the end of it what's an audition three
minutes if you can't sell yourself in
three minutes you can't say every unit
will come to you and say I don't get it
I can't do three minutes well you better
work [ __ ] won't chop the bit yeah it
peaches you up but the fat and just yet
I look up point Michie didn't cab use
one of them did punchlines yeah just get
them
that's it if it's without a setup if you
can get away with it if I get away
without kissing you and fingering you it
would be a beautiful [ __ ] walk yeah
it would be a beautiful world but you
can't but she taught you those three
minutes got me ready to audition yeah
it's late I got into the store in 97 I
started booking like a [ __ ]
that's because you're constantly
learning to just be in the moment
because I learned in between comedy and
acting and I put it together yeah I took
the acting class I paid attention I did
the scene studies yeah to a call reading
workshop I [ __ ] you know you go to
those acting classes they hook you up
with a kid that he's not a stand-up yeah
so they'll call you eight times a day
saying hey when are we going to rehearse
and you're like [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] right
yeah whoa wait a minute that's right you
gotta rehearse so you gotta call him
three times a week and go we're meeting
at 2:30 at my house this week or where
do you live I live in LA all right you
gotta go down there rush so every week
you're rehearsing and now you go onstage
at night yeah do you understand what's
going on there's a process you're just
not gonna so now while you're rehearsing
the date I'm getting better you're
acting at night you get onstage you're
doing three spots a week you're doing
three spots at night you're getting
onstage you get yeah and eventually both
worlds become one yeah and now you know
how to go into a room and start going
it's well they gave me this audition but
it only had one line welcome to the real
world that's right I'm gonna take that
one line and cut into three yeah and
stay in there for three minutes yeah
it's got a one I remember Mooney I used
to get so frustrated I come to the store
I'd be pissed off my back man I just I
blew an audition I don't know what the
hell I'm doing wrong and he like girl
you ain't gonna book anything until you
walked into the audition the way you
walk into that bar okay don't make sense
yeah yeah what he meant was I walk in
like I own it
that was my I was there every night you
know I worked I was waitress I took you
know so I walked in
there even though I'm not a comic or the
owner or whatever for some reason I walk
in that room
like that's my living room and that's
how you have to do in an audition
walking like you already got the [ __ ]
part you're just here to pick up the
check how many years are you doing
comedy when you take the blue show for
Showtime oh not that uh that's five
years ago now so the roadshow on
Showtime's five years so seven copies
yeah yeah and now you got you second
booking this is the Comedy Central with
all things comedy and Bill burr it's
almost like the what it's not called the
presents Comedy Central premium blend
remember they used to do the short sets
so these are the shorter sets which is
great because like you were just talking
about doing when Mitzi would make you do
three minutes you have to sell yourself
in three minutes right now we got to go
back down these sets or five minutes you
know I've been headlining Lee so I'm
doing an hour you start stretching
things out longer
five minutes is so hard now I'm like
dang so you just got to get back into
that motion so this week and next week I
have all set up like little five-minute
spots here and there you know just to
get back into that rhythm of editing
because I remember one night I was in a
comic I was a waitress meaning you're in
the back of the like in the kitchen in
the Comedy Store Mitzi comes in I start
talking to Mitzi or no I was telling you
a story about calling the cops for the
first time in my life and you're like
that's hilarious cuz I wound up being a
bird on my stupid it wasn't a person it
was a bird that was like chirping or
nibbling at my window and I thought it
was a person and so I you like you got a
tell Mitzi that story you got to tell me
that story it's hilarious right so I
tell Mitzi and she's like edit honey get
to the point
my whole body shut down like [ __ ] you
I'm not a comic like but I was like oh
yeah there's like things like how you
can get there quicker
you don't mean just get the point out
get the funny out and move on and she
that's all she wanted to see ever and I
remember my whole body locking up I'm
freezing like I'm never gonna become a
comic she's so mean
but she was so right that's what she's
really proud of yourself we've done I am
i I am because I'm like I said with the
acting I loved acting I only wanted to
be an actress I never wanted anything
else my mom called me Jezebel from the
time I could talk like I was just always
but it was weird cuz I would do
impressions I would make them laugh but
I thought I was acting you don't even
like I would do anything was in the news
I would reenact it for my mom to make
her laugh do stupid stuff do impressions
of everybody in the neighborhood like
people are like if the people I do
impressions up were famous
I'd be huge because I'm so good at those
impressions but it was just those people
those people yeah like my friend Cindy
or my sister Karen or this drunk lady
named Ellen that's interrupting my wife
told me I was pregnant
who what's the girl he used to dance on
stage during a shoot Chuy's shows that
the Hollywood Bowl when she picked up
her leg Adrienne Shawshank he's in DC
and she's praying Wow I love date
Adrienne was my dual confession mm-hmm
I'm the one that used to rob run Monday
nights oh man all these years I thought
it was somebody I yeah I used to rob her
like one one day a month she'd be like I
lost me hundred dollars I'm like injury
how the [ __ ] do you i'd have to i'd have
to avoid all her drinks I'm like she's
like listen that time they gave her two
bad drugs oh that was terrible she was
trying to eat what about this lip was
down here I don't know how she did that
she wasn't a different ship at one time
I took a Halawa stack of singles you
better send her a check from the Comedy
Store they will all sit like they count
money and Ricka was back this ha ha see
I used to blame his friend I walked in
to get a check you know I'm tired yeah I
walked in to get a check and I saw the
money I'm rich I was looking at a
calendar and I just picked up the money
like a joke and nobody saw it so I just
put it in my jacket I walked out it was
a stack of 100 singles right I took the
bank thing off and I drew and the thing
and I had a hundred singles I walked
down the pink Donna I gave them 50 they
gave me two 20s and
and I did something real quick but by
the time I got back to the store they're
all like the man is missing a hundred
holiday takes my cricket did and I'm
[ __ ] dying to laugh or my cricket I'm
off the [ __ ] that's why I back home
oh I know who we had on our podcast we
on the comedy star podcast we had the
Bushman Lahaie remember life ah dude you
would he's a comedy gold on a podcast
he's hysterical he always does Danish
you know Neil he always does what would
now we'll have him do are so easy he's
downtown writing a book or no he's
living in Koreatown okay you gotta get
me his oh my he goes don't Diaz don't
help me out I go whoa whoa Joe dear I
have not seen no I'm gonna I'm gonna get
Joe Diaz is not helping you out I did
not even know how I was still around
laughs you know you get him to say
certain names like he's like when I was
in Seattle I work with cocoa bean I'm
like who's cocoa bean Cobain Kurt Cobain
that's right any man he says everything
wrong it's amazing I did not even know
dude he's great he's writing a book
right now he's nicest Bamboula
his daughters his daughters what do you
call that influencer on in social media
his sons got to be a man Sean is a
basketball player yeah I still remember
two daughters and a son
I still remember gone back to in
Seattle's I didn't see ever and taking
this we party all the time we used to
get down Jewish man like the blood like
the party Joey why if you see him send
them my love I'll email I'll give him
your anything he's a great [ __ ] dude
dude Lee I would have him in this
podcast no more these blood to me I go
you just reminded me of somebody that
I've forgotten about completely like
them I'm sad because everybody went
crazy Josh wolf was like oh [ __ ] the
bush man's here like oh my god we've
known him we were kids together and
here's the funny thing I got into
trouble what he calls me Illinois that's
very funny I was lawyer
Illinois one time we I got in trouble
out here like something happened either
way well for a couple days I turn to my
allies like I got a place for you this
day I meet him outside I had a chill for
like two or three days and I pull up and
he takes me upstairs to his this hideout
no air conditioning you know the windows
open you could hear Mexican music you
get Spanish people I'm just sitting on
the living-room couch I'm just sitting
there sweating and all sudden it's 2:00
in the afternoon
I just see it Rhett just crawl across
the kitchen floor and I said why hi I
love you like a brother but this ain't
gonna happen I can give you $10 a month
cause I can't [ __ ] stay right I think
I'm gonna stay with Joey Medina instead
right out there that's how bad my
highest place I can't [ __ ] do it
but I gotta tell you something bula we
did a lot of black storm i'ma go to his
house no sleeping at 2:00 in the morning
Monday nights we get remember he used to
work on Venice Beach anyway be wearing a
loincloth Peter a spear spear but the
money in the pan any point of spirit
people go thought they don't want to put
the money it's ok I go wah ha you're
right you have a spear in their face the
high was possibly was me me Freddy la la
la high Josh wolf Marc Madison oh my god
mark has been here for long because I
showcase from it see nobody helping me
Joe Zia's yeah lets you pass him yeah he
was a regular for a while it was me he
was up there a lot that's what I'm
saying yeah
there's a lot of people just it's not go
away it's not a family a family and
people life goes different but he
brought up Joe Diaz I go I'm telling Joe
you know I never hit me up I forgot what
I even existed that's some reason same
until I heard the other podcast and I
love hard like
Oh people don't understand the
responsibilities I have now yeah I don't
have the same responsible is a headset
exactly your children everything changes
yeah that's so when you have to tell
people no or like I was just thinking
about something I do today and I'm like
[ __ ] yes my day is not finished I still
gotta go home and do this listen this is
bad I gotta go so it's gonna be tough
even doing that tonight you have so many
thing and pop up in your plate that life
goes on and what are you taping the show
we're taping April 16th you know I'm
sorry April 17th and 18th they're doing
two nights I guess at this theater
downtown what I call it the tarragon
yeah when Josh out of Myers and me spoke
and he mentioned your name I was so
proud of you and I wanted to get you on
the show to let people know your journey
to let because I started as a doorman at
wit's end I just remember the other day
when Steve Simone was it I did my
doorman state what's within Witten was a
club in Denver it was the small club a
satellite Club mm-hmm in Westminster
Colorado
you know strip mall they just had local
people to be you comic stuff like that
but I started by watching I mean I
wasn't watching for 12 [ __ ] years
right would have died I would start
economy when I was 80 well I was trying
I know I get people are like how old you
I'm like I'm almost dead relax
[ __ ] idiots like but I'm very proud
of yellow oh thank you yeah I'm thrilled
Josh Adam Meyers is on it there's a lot
of great people Rick Ingram's doing it
punky Johnson like there's gonna be a
big thing I'm or well it's a big thing
for me I don't that's the biggest name
in kind of approved by Bill I know as
the struggle he knows he's been there
he's been on a show that got canceled he
wasn't rebuilt this yeah and now he's
the comic that he is today I think my
hat's off to bilberry [ __ ] I think
he's at the store Thursday night don't
piss cuz I'm not there well I haven't
seen him yes his new special something
the big part of me like when Andrew gave
me that thing on Showtime the blue show
and he really pushed for me because they
don't know who the heck
they were like wow this girl and is this
some girl you're trying to sleep with
he's like I already did that so just
let's help her out right so they put me
in there and all I cared about was
making him proud
and now that bill burr like looked at my
stuff and was like yeah like I had to
submit stuff to them and he approved it
so to me I'm like oh my god now I care
about like just do a good job to make
bill proud like that's it that's comedy
recognizing come you know II mean comics
recognize in comics and I look up to him
yeah so it's not like [ __ ] some
network that like I watched him [ __ ]
come in and showcase and not get passed
and never get on MIT's he just looked
right past them like nothing I've ever
seen not like Louie CK what Louie she
said he was too polished but with bill
it was just like he didn't exist
because it was his manager she didn't
know them or care for them or something
there was something and then finally I
think she saw him in the main room she
goes this guy's terrific my [ __ ] we've
been telling you but you know he was New
York and he was touring he was doing his
thing anyway so well I'm happy you took
the times
Dom thank you for having me to come over
and oh I love you to death I wish you
all my favorite pocket everywhere I go
people are like oh my god you I love you
on the church I'm like I don't go to
church that much but I love this church
I'm very proud of you thank you stuck it
out put the work in and you got what was
coming to you it is work don't pretend
it's not you know you see if I go up
once a month I'm like now get to Dubai
this is a weird game and a lot of people
but any dates you like to promote oh
yeah April four through six I'm gonna be
in Kansas City at the comedy club that's
the name of it the comedy clubs great
club I'm excited my friend Dustin owns
it and it's a new brand new club so come
out support Jeremiah walkins was just
there and it was great last weekend I'll
be there April 4th through the 6th and
then House a comedy April 24th through
the 28th in Phoenix oh [ __ ] that's just
[ __ ] club that's a good oh yeah wait
yeah I love them good people I'm happy
you took the time to get
I on the other hand will be in
Pittsburgh next weekend but it's I only
got one show left Thursday night late
which we added the 10 o'clock show and
then you guys know I'm at the [ __ ]
Fitzgerald theater in Minneapolis on 419
3 4 20
and then for 20 you [ __ ] know
we're coming in deep to the Pabst
Theater in Milwaukee where Jeffrey
Dahmer killed his third victim anyway
that's how we [ __ ] do it I'll see you
guys there but before I go I got to talk
to you bit about something the church is
sponsored by stamps.com
you know why cuz time is money
[ __ ] stop wasting your precious
time going to the post office when you
can send letters and packages right from
your desk do it today with stamps calm
my wife has been on stamps calm since we
started this we sent our t-shirts out
mugs listen it's the best way to go with
just your computer the digital scale
you'll be print and postage at home boom
bang you're done is that easy but uncle
Joey there's got to be a catch what if I
need a mail this is saxophone to
Timbuktu listen with stamps calm you can
print US postage for any letter any
sized package going anywhere in the
world
right from your couch you're at the post
office right now jack and the best part
of it is the mailman will come and pick
it up they bring the US Postal Service
right to you no more lugging boxes down
to the post office more time to get
things done now you got no excuses and
here's the crazy thing about this stamps
calm is actually cheaper than the post
office you never pay full price for
stamps again and that posters meat is
our fraction of the course plus you
don't got to sign up a lease and there's
no long-term commitment how many times
am I gonna slip you to the postal office
in your life stop leaving money on the
table sign up today for stamp time all
right I use it because it saves me time
and money and that's precious and right
now they got a special offer for the
church family you ready for this one
write this down our four-week trial plus
postage and a digital scale so go to
stamps.com click the microphone at the
top of the homepage and use promo code
search ch you are CH that stamps.com at
the church start sending mail like a
doctor with stamps doctor number two
listen picking a reliable CBD company
it's tough you don't know who to go with
I mean I've gone through ten there's
eleven different labels for CBD but I
found the one that fits to me you're
ready for this
CBD line why because CBD line makes
their products from start to finish they
got you covered it comes in and they
comes in a vape it comes in cartridges
it comes in shadow and if you're not
lying to smoking it guess what they got
they got a tremendous gummy bear that'll
knock your [ __ ] socks off and they
got tensions that you put on your tongue
for thirty seconds you're swallowing
you're brand new you understand me their
products are clean Bobby and then I'm
talking about fakes here no Fugazi's
with that fake advertising you're gonna
CBD line right now and check out that
third-party lab results listen when I
saw that brochure I almost died I have
never been more impressed with a company
they back what the [ __ ] they say and
they say what the [ __ ] they're gonna do
so do me a favor go to CBD line right
down
CBD line calm right now the church
family gets 20% off at checkout just
make sure you put Church in at checkout
that CBD line.com go there right now I'm
telling you I live off the tension I'm
waiting on the Cubbies to come you guys
gonna see me popping gummies like a
[ __ ] animal and then we need to pop is
like two or three of them after you get
high boom you'll sleep like a [ __ ]
baby number three one of the most
important things you do for your health
is brushing your teeth listen my teeth
are purple because I'm 55 years old and
I've smoked everything and yet most of
us don't brush our teeth properly
equipped is the better electric
toothbrush created by dentists and
designers quip has designed to make
brushing teeth more simple affordable
and even enjoyable me I love it why
because it's got the timer it's get your
recharges easily and I can take
on the road and I got no drama let me
tell you something gentle enough on your
sensitive gums people brush too hard and
sometimes it's like the toothbrushes are
too abrasive qyp has a built-in
two-minute timer which I love every 30
seconds it remind you when to switch
sides helping you guide for a full and
even clean up to 90% of us don't brush
for a full two minutes or clean our
teeth evenly now with this multi-use
cover your month it mounts to your
mirror and on the monster slide over the
bristles for on-the-go brushing alright
it declares your sinks and your cabinets
and it makes traveling with electric
toothbrush a lot easier like I told you
quip doesn't require a chunky charger it
runs for three months on one charge that
dentist recommended schedule every three
months for just five hours three out of
four use bristles that are old worn and
effective and ineffective the brush
heads are automatically delivered on a
dentist recommended schedule of every
three months for just five dollars quip
is one of the first electric
toothbrushes approved by the American
Dental Association and has been and has
been verified five-star by thousands of
people so I'll tell you what the reason
why I love quip is why I told you it's
great for your gums and it comes with
the timer and it's easy to travel with
that's why I love quip and that's why
they're backed by over twenty thousand
dental professionals quip starts at
twenty five hours so but if you go to
quick calm slash Joey right now I'm
gonna get your first refill pack for
free with a quip electric toothbrush
who's better than you uncle Joey nobody
that's your first refill pack for free
and get quick calm slash Joey get quick
GE t qu IP dot coms last Joey again I
want to thank quip I want to thank
stamps comm and I want to thank CB by D
Lyon dot-com for support in the podcast
but most importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] for listening and for
loving us and for tuning in every
[ __ ] Monday and Thursday
I want to thank Ellen
I want to take my main man to
[ __ ] but most importantly I
want to thank you [ __ ] are
being loyal you know I got your back I
see you in Buffalo Saturday night if not
I'll see you [ __ ] in Pittsburgh
in two week stay black have a great
weekend
God love you and get ready for Monday
[ __ ] thank you guys that Thank
You Ellen